c'est sous l'oeil bienveillant de la
quintinie que poussent ici plus de neuf
cents variétés de fruits et légumes
différents
il a créé ce jardin d'éden en 1678 pour
alimenter la cour du roi soleil en
produits frais un lieu unique en son
genre qui a traversé les siècles mais
ces fondations commence à vieillir
nous avons un système hydraulique qui
date du xviie siècle qui sait colmatée
nous avons des murs qui avec le temps
perdre leur temps de vie et sur laquelle
il est très difficile aujourd'hui de
faire courir nos espaliers faire pousser
nos espagne et on n'est pas non plus
dans une situation catastrophique mais
si on n'y pense pas aujourd'hui si on
fait pas le travail aujourd'hui on
pourrait le devenir
pour mener à bien ses travaux le potager
recherchent des mécènes
classé monument historique et au
patrimoine de l'unesco c'est aussi un
campus pour l'école nationale supérieure
du paysage terrain d'expérimentation
pour les étudiants il est ouvert à tous
c'est déjà un lieu de création
culturelle avec des manifestations avec
c'était un lieu d'accueil des publics à
40000 personnes qui visitent
annuellement ce site
et c'est pour amplifier en quelque sorte
et pour donner encore plus de
rayonnement national et international
que nous avons besoin d'être accompagné
depuis plusieurs années le potager s'est
aussi lancé dans l'agro écologie la
permaculture les traitements chimiques
sont maintenant bannis comme dans cette
allée utilisés autrefois pour répandre
des pesticides la matière organique est
récupéré sur les arbres et mise en en
dha et on cultive des légumes à la place
ici sur bâche de façon à faciliter la
croissance de ces courges et de lutter
contre les adventices naturellement n'a
pas besoin de mettre d'herbicides
seuls les courges réussissent à
prospérer autant de qualités que le
potager souhaite encore développer et
qui ont séduit le world monuments fund
cette année le site a été classé comme
menacés par cette organisation
américaine
un coup de projecteur pour attirer de
potentiels mécènes